Jason you were telling us that one of
the first things that you folks do here
at chill when a filmmaker comes in with
their film is to look at their social
media numbers yeah so on the acquisition
so it's important to note that chill
does two things
the first thing we do is we have a
platform called insider access that
allows people to get in and start
engaging an audience while they're still
in pre-production going into production
going into post-production and then out
in the marketplace and the second thing
we have is a transactional
direct-to-consumer video on-demand
platform that is highly social media
driven and so by that definition
whenever we're trying to acquire a movie
one of the first things we ask ourselves
is what's the social that's the question
we ask ourselves a lot and in response
to that question we're going to look at
people's social media accounts and then
say oh this guy has ten thousand face
book likes on his page and you might
think for a second like well that guy
has a lot of facebook likes but if you
look closely you're going to find that
some of these filmmakers haven't touched
their movie for a year or more and
theirs hasn't been an update and
everybody it's just you know I always
used to phrase and it's not my phrase
but I love it it's like an abandoned
amusement apart abandoned amusement park
on the internet it's these places where
there was once a lot of fun and
happiness and now it's just it's not
there anymore and so there's a lot of
filmmakers out there and rightfully so
you go through the process of making a
movie it's a pain in the butt and you're
lucky if you still speak to your casting
crew let alone you know you want to keep
promoting the thing a year after you
know you've been to the festivals and
you're fatigued and you just you just
want it to be done you want to just move
on to the next thing well that can
actually hurt you that can hurt you from
an acquisitions perspective because now
you know that when you're working with
this filmmaker they're not going to be
engaged what they're looking for is just
the hand of movie off and say okay you
know my movies distributed now and that
might be fine for some filmmakers but
for other filmmakers that actually want
to make their movie a viable business it
can be a hindrance if you let that stuff
die so strong social media
is definitely appealing and I've been on
several panel discussions now where with
film festival directors and they said
they're actually looking for the exact
same thing they want to go after movies
and acquire movies for their film
festival where the filmmakers actively
engaged in actively promoting with the
thought being is if we get this into our
festival they're going to be able to
fill the seats and so underlying all the
underlining all the different things I
talked about engaging an audience there
is a degree of commerce here that if
people are investing time and money in
your project they're looking for the
safest return the lowest risk return and
so engaging on your social media and
staying up to date is one way to
demonstrate that so what can you advise
filmmakers on their social media in
terms of their Facebook and their
Twitter not just on how active they are
but what they're doing in that activity
what can you tell them well the
activities should always be geared
towards whatever it is that that you
know whatever the conversation is keep
it going in that direction so obviously
if you've made your movie about purple
pinecones don't go on there one day and
start talking about obesity in America
it probably just wouldn't be a good fit
so stay on topic but also kind of make
an interesting and reveal yourself as a
real person behind the guise of I'm the
guy making the movie which frankly is
another art in and of itself and some
people are better at than other people
but genuine conversation again marketing
is a conversation so figure out how to
keep that conversation going and what
are some tips on keeping yourself human
but maybe not you know it's not a video
diary right we're not talking personal
video diaries but keeping yourself human
I think it's okay to get on there and
you know some behind the scenes footage
is nice every once in a while especially
if you're still in production I'd love
to see you know the the heated
discussion that you have with your
director of photography over why
somebody thinks it should go this way
and somebody thinks it should look a
different way
another thing that those are always
heated discussions but that kind of
stuff is interesting because now you
feel more a part of the production
before the movies even made
and I think I think that's a good way to
engage without showing too much
you